what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
december 28th santa got hit by a car who
gives a [__]
it's a whole new week with a whole new
set of rules
and i'm coming to you from the
[__] heart of jersey
where draftkings is [__] home and
it's all about
because while the holiday season may be
winding down
the sports calendar is in full [__]
effect
it's monday night tonight you know what
they're throwing at you they're throwing
the bills
against the [__] patriots at you the
bills are minus seven
the patriots need this the dolphins i
mean this is a [__] big game tonight
all right
you got a total you got a [__] over
and under you got a parlay there
a nickel [__] player which 2500
tonight
can you beat that can you make more than
that washing dishes
or whatever the [__] it is you do on
your ip no so get the draftkings right
now
there's no better place to get it on
action than draftkings
america's copyrighted sports book if you
haven't tried it yet
you might as well stick 10 bananas up
your ass what the [__] are you waiting
for
to celebrate this year's college
football playoffs
you ready draftkings has given all new
users
the chance to bet on any semi-final team
to win the championship at 100 to one
odds
joey but what are you saying i don't
understand
i can't do math that fast i'm dyslexic
no you're a [__] [__] that's what
you are
draftkings is giving all new users the
chance to bet on any semi-final team
to win the championship at 100 to one
odds you heard me
all you got to do is better buck on any
semi-final team
to win the championship if your team
wins
who picks up the yardstick you do
[__]
so don't forget basketball head to the
app right now
and check out our daily odds boost
download the top-rated draftkings
sportsbook app today
right now no more [__] before the
[__] podcast starts
use promo code joey when you're signing
you get 100 to one odds on any
semi-final team to win this whole
[__]
kitten caboodle that's code joey
joey joey joey you [__] sucker for new
players to get the shot
at 100 on this semi-final
this week it starts this week but the
party starts tonight
who the [__] are you getting all right
you got the [__] bills
you got the patriots tom brady's getting
this dick sucked in brazil
don't worry about nothing it's time for
you to make some [__] money a nickel
player tonight
walk saturday with 2 500. you got the
game you got the time you got the total
forget about it we're gonna parlay we're
gonna go [__] deep
deep deep but it starts with you
draftkings
sportsbook app now use promo code
joey and for limited time only at
draftkings sportsbook and listen
this is the part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 or older if you're
under 21
go play [__] matchsticks or something
go light your [__]
little brother on fire i don't give a
[__] new jersey indiana pennsylvania
tennessee colorado deposit
bonus requires a 25-time playthrough
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
slash watchbook for details you got a
gamma problem this is a serious problem
i can't have you lurking around
draftkings if you have a
uh a gambling problem i know a lot of
people like grabbing problems they're
not good
so do yourself a favor knock this [__]
off call 1-800 gambler
g-a-m-b-l-e-r-o if you're in indiana
call 1-809
with it but if you're saying
[__] gambling [__] my wife [__] the kids
[__] the car payment giraffe king sports
rap
is for you download it pressing joey
and let's make some [__] cash all
right
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion who the [__] are you kidding when
it comes to cbd
they are the best who told you that
uncle joey did how do i know
because i'm a fat [__] but i'll try this
in my knees and i go to the gym four
times a week and i walk and i ride a
bike and i do everything i can
and what helps me get through is the cbd
lion
i pop in the leave from time to time if
i tighten up a little bit too much
but it's cbd line that helps with my
inflammation
my pain helps my little low with the
anxiety
and it comes in 18 different ways to
ingest it
from the [__] back ball to the
strawberry raspberry
tropical frog gummies to the roll-on for
your shoulders and your knees and your
joints
to the thousand milligram tinctures they
got a [__] tremendous dark chocolate
you can see i've already dipped into it
you gotta eat dark chocolate it's good
for you anyway but they give you they
got dark chocolate
milk chocolate cbd and they got vapor
pens listen
if they got it cbd lion has it
it's that simple you're not dealing with
some [__]
moulin rouge at the [__] store that
don't know dick
he basically got out of seventh grade
and you're asking him about terpenes you
dumb [__]
go to cbd lion read about cbn
cbd terpenes and how it affects you
what products help you the most what you
can get out of cbd lion
it starts today the [__] new year is
thursday you're still pandering
i'm going to exercise with my ankle
cbd line you're [__] right now
pressing code joey
church whatever the [__] you want to
press in big dick mcgick
and get 20 off sent to your house just
tell them joey sent you all right
that's it no more [__] complaining
i'm gonna work out but my neck
i sucked a thousand dicks when i was 13.
well
cbd line is here to help you all right
right now cbdline.com
read up on the third party lab results
and let's [__] do this all right
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
[__] draftkings and welcome
to the mind of joey diaz what do you
think of those shirts [__] go
[__] yourself
you wanted to sign up for the dollar
tier go hang out with them now you [__]
i tried to tell you
uncle joey was delivering the goods like
judas priest and [__]
80. let's do this [__] i love you
[__]
look who it
welcome to is joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
monday the 28th
of december ready for another fun-filled
week
happy belated christmas tea if i didn't
see you
happy belated christmas to your families
i hope you guys did great
uh you know it was what it was i had a
great time
i really did man uh l.a christmas
in l.a you know everybody the last day
of
uh civilization
in l.a is usually that friday before
christmas
so this year would have been the 18th
the day of my original surgery
and it's so funny that you know people
have a half day and
right from the [__] office they go
right to the airport
they disappear and the whole christmas
spirit disappears from my life
you know like there's no christmas
spirit there's nothing yeah there's some
kids
nobody sings in front of your house
nobody does nothing now
the type of guy that sang in front of
houses get the [__] out of here
i didn't sing in front of a house i
never wanted none of that
but when you have a family you know
things change and uh
you're looking for different things this
is one of the best christmases i had in
years
i mean it really did uh what is it we're
here monday the 28th
christmas basically started on wednesday
for us
it started a friday before you know
people had little outdoor gatherings
with eaters
and hot cocoa and [__] cakes and [__]
like that
god knows what i weigh i did take good
care of myself
there was four places i went in a day
four parties they had pizza and i didn't
eat a slice at all four of them
so how's that for you i had one slice of
pizza this week
so i'm trying you know i'm saying you
gotta you gotta [__] and if not this
this place will kill you you know how
many [__] people knocked on this door
to give us cookies and [__] like that
italian plate
because half the neighborhoods from
staten island the best
the best so they knocked on the door
with cookies and stuff every night look
it was just it was everything i wanted
to be
it was everything i wanted for my
daughter to be
it was everything i wanted for my wife
to see i knew that
there was life outside l.a and i'm
[__]
ecstatic that it all went down uh
we went out for christmas night we went
to a friend's
very low key uh they sang
christmas songs i think we were home by
9 30 10
got [__] up drank a bottle of coke
keto last week
some cuban eggnog you know you gotta do
what you got to do
uh but i'm back i'm back on the [__]
program now i worked out four days a
week so
it was no big deal i still lifted
yesterday uh
saturday and uh i just left there this
morning so we're back
we're already rolling in the carpet for
the beginning of the year that's it
as far as i'm concerned 2020 is behind
me
2021 is the major concern we got the
movie coming out
we got stand up coming back you know
whether it comes back with a vaccine or
not i'll be back doing outdoor gigs in
april
like a [__] i've got uncle
vinnie's the fifth and the sixth
and i got the surgery on the eighth say
10 20 days after that i'm back on stage
working new material and we're going
after it with or without the kovid
or i'm going on stage with colvin i'll
put like a [__] stick man and
give him coven and we'll go on stage
together like a two-man theme
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do you're gonna stay in your house and
hide because of [__] coping another
year
you can't do it i understand for people
who are going to be working from home or
not
but there's ways to tighten up your game
you already did nine months of it
it's getting old so maybe set up the
schedule
do an hour get up go for a walk and do
another hour
get up call make some calls you know now
well now you're getting better at it
don't expect that now corporations and
businesses aren't seeing this and saying
you know what
we could go from a [__] 8 000 a month
nut
to 2 000 a month and just give
assignments out
the world's going to change the job
market's going to change
everything is going to change which is
good we would do for a [__] change
things are getting a little [__]
boring with the [__] uh the same
[__] all the time you know and it's good
people
who are burnt out doing old jobs and now
doing new [__] jobs
you know i was burnt down on [__]
stand-up
i'm very happy now that i got to go down
there once a week and do it
do you think i want to go back to two
shows a week every other week with a
[__] theater and planes and [__]
i'm not ready for that right now i feel
funny again i feel happy again
my family's good mike's good we're
running smooth
smoked and [__] and tremendous reefer
the patreon is going great so
i got no regrets i did my time and i'm
ready to go
we got a subject to talk about this week
which was uh very interesting how it
fell on my lap
and i wrestled with it for a few days
before i
wanted to bring it to podcast because
i'm not here to cause any problems
i'm just telling you how an evolution
of a bad situation came out and
basically he was the first comic that
got
cancelled throughout this whole thing
and he basically canceled himself
you know last week we were talking about
tom cruise
how he went off on his job and you know
people didn't like it and some people
criticize him
a [__] likes me a [__]
like me
who is a fan of tom cruise whatever his
religious preference is i don't give a
[__] if he's a scientologist what are
you gonna do the guy's waiting for
martians
that's his business that's what he does
on sundays you know what i'm saying
who gives a [__] you know what i do on
sundays i go to church and
try to not get hypnotized by the [__]
uh pedophile smoke
you sit there and you hold on to your
breath so everybody's got
their own trials and tribulations on a
sunday you know what i'm saying
uh you know he went off about
coving the movie and you know uh social
distancing and
some people took offense to it and i
loved it because
most people did take offense to it
especially the people in l.a
especially the five people that quit
that job
now i'm not saying that you you know i
have
uh stuck up for myself in those
situations
i have stuck up for myself when i've
been right
and a director or producer has been
wrong and yelled at me
i could tell you if you look at my imdb
joey dears
i've been on a thousand [__] projects
and i think i man let's just sum it up
to three
where i had proj uh problems on a
project let's just
sum it up to three you know uh
the one commercial i did for arby's
where the director was just being an
[__]
um american gun
i think that i was being an [__] and
so were they and i got the brunt of it
that's what happens
[__] falls downhill and uh
the longest yard i was a [__] towards
the end you know
basketball i robbed them blind from
their [__]
roller skates [__] them they're still on
tv
south park they got they got more roller
skates in the roller skate company
so i'm not worried about that but pretty
much
um you know with comedy and stuff i
i was always trying to be a gentleman i
always tried to encourage other people
uh you know i see somebody on stage
doing a great joke bro i'll go up to him
afterwards and say hey man that made me
laugh
you know whatever i'm not going to go up
to you and tell you a bad joke is a good
joke i'm not fake
that's not what i do either i'm not
going to sit in the back and go aha
you know those fake comic laughs to let
you know that
i laugh if it's [__] funny but
there's people who get
insulted if you say things to them they
take it the wrong [__] way
and i've apologized to people because
people have said i
you kind of said it the wrong way no i
said it the right way
you just took it the wrong way because
you're a [__] [__] and you don't
want to [__] accept it
and you don't wanna you know somebody to
call you the [__] out well
for me to tell you the story i gotta
tell you this story in the beginning
and in chunks and uh
we're gonna take it from there i got a
call
about 10 days ago from a friend of mine
and he was saying that
john caparulo had just worked
the club you know about a month earlier
three weeks
months earlier and he was bitching and
complaining and
saying negative [__] about the store
[__]
all of the skies it's gonna be a parking
lot anyway
that they're gonna knock it down and uh
you know
i feel bad for him when i heard uh and
there was more stuff
but who gives a [__] when i heard the
stuff he said
i took a minute i hung up the phone and
i gotta be honest here i didn't feel
good about
what had happened because what
kappa rule was really mad about was that
he wasn't putting a documentary and he
wasn't
considered a piece of the church family
and
i'm here to tell you and this is
nobody's fault and i'm not blaming
anybody
or anything uh
caparulo should have been in it but
because his behavior
he wasn't put in it so let's start
on what he did why he shouldn't be in
there and how this
all went down i knew capriles since day
one he was a sweetheart of a kid
very quiet very introverted
one day like everybody else at that
comedy store from hazel's trail
the common morales to all the people
after a while you start to see him the
girl that made it to saturday night live
uh you start to see them and
after three six nine months they start
to get a little confidence they've been
around comics
they've they've gotten to go up on stage
a few times
you know it's it's it's an easier place
uh you know one night you walk him and
and you'll see him on stage hosting and
you're like [__] and
capitolo capitola was a funny [__]
guy you know he was younger than me
he was there with bobby lee and all
those guys
i gotta tell you they were having a
great time and because they were having
a great time they were making me have a
great time
and i i still remember one night
caparoola was a doorman
and he asked me for advice he asked me
about how
um you get more spots and duncan
trussell was the
talent coordinator and duncan was
walking through the building i called
them over and go duncan come here for a
second
talk to uh john he wants to know how to
get more spots and
we're like i don't know if you know this
you got to pay for your spots
and he's like what do you got to pay
we're like 15 it's like that's good
that's absurd
that's exactly what i get what are you
going to do john you got to pay
you want three spots it's 45 a week i'm
here to collect every friday for duncan
and me and duncan are laughing he's like
that's absurd
and we're like we're [__] with you
john i mean that's how long
we know john okay sweetheart of a kid
never had a problem knew him when he was
dating girls still a great guy
and then what happens when you stick
with something
success finally happens and he started
getting a little successful you know he
started uh
i think he went to montreal and
he got watched up there and you know
from being at the store
his his act was [__] tremendous
and he got a deal from fox and
i still remember him coming in and
saying that fox gave him a box of shirts
t-shirts because you know john used to
wear white t-shirts and stuff all the
time
and listen uh at that time was 2 000
something
uh i had already learned as a comic and
as a human being that
you couldn't be jealous you have to be
happy for the people in your
circle especially at the store because
when one person moves up the notch
that means you're gonna move the notch
so i was happy for him but i noticed
something else
over the following couple weeks john
caparulo's head start to get big
little things how he parked the car he
quit his doorman job
he was walking around you know saying
little things he was still a
happy-go-lucky
john but uh you could see that
the deal had changed him a little bit it
didn't affect me
i still loved him for everything that he
was
he was funny as [__] you know and uh
this went on for a while you know and it
was great and bob
and john and all of us and john's
getting deals and
then he did something for comedy central
and i saw him one day
and it was a different side of john he
was very upset
his face was red and he was mad
because he wanted to give the check back
to comedy central
he didn't think the special was good
enough and that's the first time i
noticed that there might be a problem
with this guy i'm like
he's back here cursing you know you got
a guy like me that can't get a [__]
special i'm so bad
and he's got a special he's back here
yelling and screaming
how he wants to give the money back and
blah blah blah blah
in the meantime rogan's catching
momentum
rogan's a powerhouse from fear factor
you know
uh you can't deny it that he's bringing
in most of the people
on fridays and saturday nights into the
club
well that's you know
gets a little couple people pissed off
not to mention
they would give him a half hour since so
many people were coming in to see him
they would give him from 11 to 11 30
they would put me up from a quarter to
11 to 11
and hari from 10 30 to a quarter to 11.
so we basically jacked the [__]
original room
lineup from whatever per rogan rogan was
like you're going in front of me or he
goes in front of him
everybody else has to suck your dick
that's great
but when you do that again you create
tensions and people there was little
whisperings they wouldn't say it to me
they know better to say it to me
but there was little whisperings you
know you heard little whisperings going
around
at that time i was deep into my
addiction
so i didn't really give a [__] you could
suck my dick anyway
so this one on and then
again you're gonna have to fact check me
on dates on this
uh maxim did the men of comedy tour
with charlie murphy and joe rogan
and john heffron
and while they were on the road i would
still call in for spots down to the
store
this has to be 2006 guys the beginning
of 2007
maybe 2005 maybe now 2006
2007 because i was still doing coke
i'm up there one night i'm about ready
to go up
i'm not going up at no 10 45.
joe wasn't there to take care of me i
was i was having an 11
30 spot maybe 11 45
and john and tommy come up to me and
they're like hey man and
john had a hat on he had like his chest
out
okay and i'm not listen i was deep into
the addiction
i was deep into what was going on in my
world my world was getting really dark
and you know something had to be done
eventually and i looked at these two
guys
and they're like when your daddy comes
back
things are gonna change and i'm like
whoa whoa what are you talking about
guys
and they're like when joe rogan comes
back it's not going to be how it is
and i go well listen i don't even know
why you're telling me this from what the
[__] are you telling me this for
tell me what are you telling me this
[__] for they said a bunch of other [__]
i did my spot i went home and it wasn't
until i got home
and i was like those guys just
did a declaration of [__] war on me
like i didn't pick it up at the time you
haven't
you ever get into an argument or
something
and you don't really know what happened
till after it happened you get in the
car and you drive away
that's why i felt i was like they just
declared war on me they didn't even know
if i hadn't had three bumps in me
already and i wasn't a scared junkie
i'd wanna put a little gun down there
and fight them both but i said you know
what
i'll give them breathing who the [__] am
i i don't
i don't give a [__] about this [__] so
that's exactly what i did i didn't say
nothing about it
i avoided john you know i always make
mental notes
he got away with this one the next one
i'll [__] say something to him
and tommy he could suck my dick through
so
time goes on you know maybe a month two
months go on
i get a call it's tommy
and he's telling me that [__] carlos
mancia is coming in there
and bumping people and he doesn't feel
that carlos should be bumping people i
tell him listen
last time i checked when you're a
[__] you have your own tv show you
could bump whatever the [__] you want to
bump
so bump your way off this phone call
and go [__] yourself what he was trying
to do is plant the seed
to me to call rogan to get rogan all
fired up that that
that wasn't happening he wanted he was
trying to tell me that caparoola was
funnier than carlos
and that carlos shouldn't be go be
allowed to go in there
and [__] do his thing and i was
totally against it i was like no
people been bumping all along you got
the wrong [__] guy
so at that time i was getting the fat
lump removed from my neck
i had my own dilemmas going and
sure enough one night i hear rogan gets
thrown out of there
and you know rogan gets into it with
mike feydman
i look at the video and then
rogan uh people were sticking up for joe
and they said that they had to go to the
store on friday night
to uh do uh like a protest
and people didn't go down there
and i thought for me that was the end of
my
career and my days at the comedy store
i had a back joe uh for years
people bothered joe about carlos
muncilla
and that he's a joke thief finally joe
sticks up
and these comics folded like a bunch of
[__]
folding chairs you know and i saw that
and i
and for years i thought i was part of
something i thought it was part of sons
of anarchy
i thought it was part of hell's angels i
thought it was part of the mafia
i thought it was part of something i i
wasn't even part of the boys club of
america those [__] you know
the boy scouts of america that showed me
comedy really had nothing as
a brotherhood they have certain cliques
yes
but as a brotherhood we that night
nobody stepped up for joe so
i knew what path now now you know what
this means you gotta get two guns
you just can't have the gun in your
holster you gotta get one in your side
piece now because
now we see how this game is played this
game is not played
by awful one one for all
this game is played of oh you guys want
to
do that like when you saw the document
the distort documentary
leno crossed the line there's always one
comic that's gonna do what he wants to
do
because uh desperation is a [__]
in this world
i'm not saying jay was desperate but you
know
a sponsor sponsor spot people will do
anything for a spot
they'll sell their mother for a spot yes
they will suck your dick
for a spot in l.a yes they will so
uh you know i just stopped going down
there
and i focused my energies on another
thing you know
greg garcia gave me a recurring role on
my name is
earl i had some other stuff going on but
i still kept in touch with a handful of
people from the store
and every time
uh again i'm lying to you if i said
every time
but every let's say every five
conversations i had with somebody from
the store
john caparulo's name popped up
like i said i had no hatred for him uh i
liked him i thought he was a funny comic
i respect them
i was a little off kilter with him
from his remarks that night and
but now i was starting to
lose respect for him from the things i
was hearing
he was telling comics to their faces
that he sucked
he was telling comics that they couldn't
go up to
after him he had tommy in his back
pocket
and they were uh you know just doing
shitty things together with the other
comics
and not the comics from the improv or
the live factory
or the haha or [__] you know comics
from other sectors
if you want to go to war that way i get
that as a goof
but you were doing it to comics in the
comedy store we all worked together
we were all made by mitchy shaw it was a
commune
it was a compound it was all these
beautiful
[__] things and yeah i'm not here to
[__] tell you
i was johnny perfect i was in this
norton coke
and getting my dick sucked and eating
[__] and doing drugs
you know i was doing my thing too but at
the same time
i wasn't up there putting down comics or
torturing them or telling
people who could go up or who can't go
up or you know whatever yeah
i ran the [__] open mic on sunday
nights and mitchy shaw
you know comics would sign their names
up that were [__]
not she what she didn't like them
so they'd be there all day to sign their
name and when i give her the list you go
get him out of here get him out of there
and the people thought it was me it's
not me it's mitzi i would never
throw anybody this is an art
you do what you do but throughout this
[__]
i stayed out of the store from 2000
maybe uh seven
to 2013 and i gotta tell you that every
month
i heard something else about this
caparoulo guy
saying this doing this
him and tommy doing this
tommy telling girls they weren't funny
i was just hearing about this this new
place that i wasn't a part of
it was an ego place at the time
crystalia was developing there
you know i don't i think caparulo had a
problem with him but
you know things had happened that uh on
the wall west tour
it was capparullo and brett ernst and
sebastian
and i met ahmed i think i'm not sure
don't quote me on this and uh
there was a problem there you know
uh he was having a problem with bobby
lee
uh john cabarrus was having a problem
with rick ingram
sean caparula was just becoming a prom
at the store
and i i had i had no dog in the fight
it had nothing to do with me so
i stayed out of it i get a call one day
that they call time they caught tommy
with his hands in the cookie jar
uh you know i was blown away because i
always thought he was a trust fund kid
and for him to be stealing hundred
dollar bills
and again i'm a thief i'm not going to
judge him i'm just telling you
the facts just in case everybody anybody
wants to come back
and go no no no the facts they hired a
guy to go in there with hundreds
they put the hundreds and they went they
looked back the hundreds of gun tommy
was behind the register
they fired him he took the [__]
firing he saw
on some island playing [__] uh
what's that [__] dude's name he's
saying
yeah he's singing jimmy buffett songs at
a [__] bar right now
uh wasted away in candor margarita
margaritaville now this leaves john
caparulo
i get the call to go down there i go
down there
when i got the call to go back to the
store in 2014
i said this is the chance to redeem
myself
for all the [__] i had done down there
before i had met terry
you know i was on a complete tear
i was on a complete tear as an addict
you know i was drinking i was uh
i was a comic man i was just
being a young stupid
[__] comic that's it and everything
that goes down with it and whatever was
going on down there was going on down
there
you know you guys have heard 20 stories
and
uh you have no idea what was going on
down there so
for you to sit there and judge or for
any of these
girls today these comics today
to sit there and judge about what was
going on 20 years ago
they have no [__] idea so they could
all shut their mouths and go [__]
themselves
97 98 2000 was a way different time at
the economy store than what it was today
so i get the call to go back
in 2013. again
i don't expect nothing i don't make no
demands
nothing i'm very happy doing comedy
living the way i'm living
i get a chance to go back to the store
you know
i go back down there [__] great night
tuesday night
no prom i went down there like a
thursday i was going down there for
about a month
my return to the comedy store was
in august i remember because i had a
colonoscopy
uh like august something and lee drove
me down for the thing and then
that week i started going to the store i
was at the store
maybe two months before i even saw kappa
ruler
my concerns were not kappa ruler my
concerns were
personally myself going back down there
after about two months of
me going down there i noticed that joe
rogan started going down there
and the boys were back down there ari
was trying to go back down there
and all this [__] okay all right
like i said um i got a daughter
i uh
i got a wife i got a podcast
i got a career on the road i'm not even
thinking about john caparulo
and one night i pull up down there
and i hear arguing
and i see all this [__] arguing and
it's
uh supposedly john caparulo had moved
farther away from the comedy store
and he got caught in traffic and he
couldn't make his spot
so on the way down they had to find
other comedians to fill his spots
and the only comment that was there was
joe rogan well
john caparulo doesn't like firing fire
he doesn't like going up behind
good comics he wants to be the best
comic in the room
he wants to he does not want to fire
follow heat at all by no means
at no [__] expense heat is not as
it is a [__] thing so
he's calling the the front girl that i
could
get on the podcast and tell you the
story and just tell them no
don't let them put rogan on anybody else
my broken anybody asked about wrong
again don't let them be broken on
i guess they put rogan on he came in
and he either left or threw a fit
i think one time he left that they had
put somebody else up
and one time he threw a fit i know about
the fit
for sure i could [__]
you could fact check me on the fit for
sure whether he left or not is something
different
but i think i could come down to the
fact that
he did leave one night because they
didn't follow want they don't want to
follow the heat
well right away i'm like look at this
[__] already starting [__]
problems
so i think after the rogan thing because
the
the the rogan thing happened
and he got really upset and then after
he think the night he left
he just stopped going to the store so i
went back to the store in august
rogan went back in october and capper
rulo probably stopped coming into
november
so that december 31st as we usually did
every year i did the recap
of the year with rogan
on the jre podcast and
he goes man it's good to see you you
killed last night i mean everybody was
killing we were having a great time i
mean
it was it was way different than i
remembered in 98
97 you know we were doing well as comics
nobody was on the tonight show or
nothing nobody had netflix specials
but it was great to see people from the
bottom of your heart
you were up there cheering for arie i
was cheering for duncan
i was cheering for bird i was cheering
for tom
i was cheering for rick ingram you know
you were cheering for the people in
front of you whitney cummings
eliza schlesinger i'm up there [__]
dying of laughter
and you know and then you got this
[__] sleeping pill
this [__] capital ruler guy who walks
in
you know tells his death and then
[__] leaves you got sebastian
you got bobby lee you got all this love
and all this positivity and then you got
this
walking [__] hemorrhoid that would go
up there and you could see he was hot so
he stopped coming up there
so we're sitting in the rogan studios
and rogan's like man we've been having a
great time lately
at the store i wonder what the [__] it
is do you have any idea i go yeah
tommy and that [__] [__] capper ruler
were gone
that's that's the truth that's the i
thought it was the honest to god [__]
truth you know
two days later my twitter handle is
blowing the [__] up with cap
ruler hey [__] you and you know i'm
young
i'm a little you know not young
but i'm buckwild and i go at him [__]
you
[__] that we start going back and forth
i'm reading a book on roberto duran at
the time
and when brother durant fought sugar ray
leonard they were up in toronto for the
first fight
and sugar ray leonard went to uh
uh introduced his wife to her brother
duran
he goes honey look who it is roberto
let's go home and say hello to him
so they walked over and said hello to
brother duran
robert duran took one look at him goes i
can't wait to [__] her in the ass
[__] sugar ray cracked he cracked so
hard
he ended up losing the [__] fight i
mean that's the psychological warfare of
it so
when he was going at me i was going at
him psychologically
john i'm gonna [__] your wife in the ass
i'm saying all this [__] on twitter
because i'm i'm just a [__] animal
i never met his wife i i heard she's a
beautiful person
and i shouldn't have been saying those
things but it's all fair and love and
warm with comedy store congress
and you've been a real [__] scumbag
for comics for the last seven years
and it's ending [__] right now it's
ending
like it was ending so i just [__]
went off [__] you
we threatened each other he's gonna
[__] do this to me i'm gonna do that
to him so i said listen
let's just eliminate the whole [__]
thing come on down to the store tonight
[__] i'll be that eight o'clock
and i get down to the store and some
people are hearing about
it some people got their eyes open and
sure enough
he pulls up with a z28 and he gets
out and he walks right towards me you
know and he [__]
stepped up i don't know his face was all
red and stuff
and before i could let him get set you
know me dog i'm hudson county straight
up
straight up new york city straight up
hudson county
something's coming from somewhere i
already got a brick
that's loose but all i got to do is clap
and the vibration will loosen it
and it'll hit you in the [__] head
i'm one of those guys so as he went to
turn right into me like ah
before i could catch him and he could
catch the leverage
instead of leg kicking him i did the
second best thing the leg kick
a spit to the face a spit to the face is
very tremendous because
he didn't even hear it coming it was
already sitting in the gargoyles of my
[__] throat
and i got him half in his mouth and half
in his face
and he started going like this it was
the funniest thing he ever seen because
when he landed
as his head landed it was perfect it
just went tooth
and he's like and he went back and he's
like how dare you
you know his his ego was so [__] big
and he went to throw a punch at me and
thank god there was a
an open mic comic there was sweetheart
another guy who's mad at me and i'm mad
i'm not mad at him anymore things got
out of hand
that desperation you know everybody
thinks that somebody could change your
life in
in uh in hollywood they really can't you
have to do the work yourself
but this poor nice sweetheart of an open
mic
before [__] uh john caparulo could
turn
he catches john caparulo with a points
to the [__] head
you you couldn't have written this
[__] thing and nobody said anything
time just stopped cap ruler looked
around he ran into the main room
and i guess he had to follow marin and
marin was up on stage
and marion said he brought him up and he
was bringing him up
he kept wiping his eyes like what
happened
he's like you're not going to believe
what happened so marin waited for him
and he got off
he told mary that i spit in his face and
blah blah blah and you know
and then he went home and we went back
and forth to add it again and i just
[__] told him i
said listen man your best bet is not to
come down now
you know uh you did a lot of bad [__] to
a lot of good comics
you had a lot of good comics feelings
and one thing about me
i take one thing really [__] serious
i take when people [__] with people's
dreams when people [__] with people's
dreams
you're a certain type of [__] animal
so
he was [__] with people's dreams man
he told a lot of things a lot of bad
people he told a lot of good people some
bad
things he judged them he judged that
comedy he judged their jokes
there's a couple of those [__]
at the store
that didn't want them following you like
oh i'm not gonna follow you that was a
particular [__] he knows what
the [__] it is
creators of shows and [__] he'd be
calling at him don't let
i don't want to follow joey and then he
would come up to me before my shows and
say like to try to piss on my leg like
oh are you going to go rogue tonight or
are you going to be
organized and i would tell them i'm
going to [__] do what i do
[__] but if you want to you can sit
down with me and teach me how to write
comedy because
you could write all the comedy you want
you'll never be as funny as i will
writing jokes and being funny is two
different [__] things
so you could sit there and write all the
netflix specials you want
that don't mean you're [__] funny i
can read the yellow pages blindfolded
and [__] make you [__] dial up so
uh i don't even know where
where we were at you know john
took a breather he started going to the
comedy magic club
uh adam from the store told him to take
a breather
you know right away he went at rogan he
went at me
he went out a bunch of us saying that
this was a conspiracy to get him out
no it was everybody wanted him out
nobody wanted him there
he had made that place a living [__]
hell
and he knew it he started going down to
the orange
uh whatever the comedy magic club [__]
them to
and uh he got thrown he they hit him
with a [__] glass
they threw a glass on some trump hater
or a trump lady
trump supporter threw a glass at him and
you know he must i saw that and i felt
bad
i wasn't happy about that like he's
getting beat up outside but then
he did the ultimate sin he did two
things
that cost him everything one he put out
a podcast after he got hit
about you know he ran with the bully
thing and the whole thing
and nobody bullied them when him and
tommy were having a good time bullying
people
you know everybody was jumping up and
down now when it
when the tables turned he didn't like it
he put out this whole podcast about
getting bullied and blah blah blah
guess what everybody talked to each
other
nobody said a word the podcast
disappeared
he fizzled into the night and then
mitchy sure died
they checked around
they called him the town coordinator
some of the managers said you know what
he did his time here
he was a real man call him up he was
here during mitzi
i agreed captain rulo should be here
everybody
they invited him to go down there he
went down there
he picked three [__] fights he
started three fights
he started three arguments with three
different comics arie
steve runners easy and bobby lee so they
gave him another chance
and he went down and he was a jerk off
again
you know he was a joe jerkoff again
so you know when this club owner told me
that he was disgruntled that he was
saying the club was over
anyway you know uh
uh 20 years ago joe diaz would have been
very happy he would have said [__] him
no i feel really bad for how this ended
for john
that's why i wanted to tell this story
you know i can't imagine him and his
wife watching that documentary and not
seeing even three minutes of john
but hey there were a lot of other people
that deserved to be in that documentary
that weren't in that documentary either
my heart goes out to them
but john no uh
i'm sorry you didn't get put in a
documentary and you didn't deserve to
get put in the documentary for what you
did
you went against the people that mitchy
shaw
was trying to rise up that's what you
did you went against us
and uh
you know what my police record is gonna
live forever
then i [__] got arrested and i did
time
burglary whatever the [__] i did
that documentary from showtime is gonna
be up for [__] ever
and i wasn't one of the stars of that
[__] documentary
but i was in it and that that means
i'm gonna be in there forever and the
sad thing about
this is because of your [__] ego
because of your [__] ego and your
inability to work as a team
and to be a part of a family listen i
don't i'm not part of no clubs i'm not
part of affiliations
you know i'm not with the rampers i'm
not with a [__]
biker gang or whatever i'm a human being
and i treated people like a human being
yeah at times i [__] up i made a guy
get in the trunk with a machine gun i
wasn't all
dairy that wasn't all the perfect
[__] thing but when i got to that
comedy store
my first tenure there i was just a wild
comic i didn't know what i was doing
but when i went back there as my second
tenure i went back as a mature adult
comic
and i had a lead by example and that's
what i tried to do and i tried to be a
gentleman
to the younger [__] comics and that's
what you didn't do
you were a scumbag them and that's why
now
you're going to be miserable the rest of
your life over not being on this
documentary
and being treated like that from the
people from the store
i feel bad for you and i pray for you
and i light a candle for you
that your life changes and that your
anger
from this situation goes away because
it's really going to alter your comedy
and right now what you have to worry
about
is the mileage you have to feed your
house payment
your wife and your kid your beautiful
wife your beautiful child
and your beautiful family john caparulo
i have nothing against you
what i had against you was your ego and
your inability
to [__] apologize to be a [__] man
and say yeah i did it who cares
nobody would care in a year you would
have been back at the store
you've been rocking and rolling and you
would have been one of us
family again you chose to be angry
walk around with a red face and go to
the comedy [__] magic club and do
magic tricks
with those [__] humps so if you're
upset
if i upset you in any way i wasn't born
to upset you
or to cancel you all i wanted to do
was to call you out for what you had
been doing
to some of the comments at the store and
the attitude you came up to me up with
with that night
with you and tommy i should have taken
his boat and laid his boat on [__]
fire
but i was too [__] up on my cocaine
and with all my proms and with
everything else
but today i'm the man i want to be you
know i'm very happy with who i am i'm
very happy that i did my tenure at the
store
i'm happy i did my tenure on the
documentary
and i'm not happy that you're not on it
i wish you would have been on it you
deserve to be on it what i'm not happy
with
is that you didn't apologize and i'm not
happy that you never came clean with us
and looked us in the eye
and told us what you did and that's it
and that's that
i hope everybody learned the lesson
today about life
and when somebody calls you out
it may bother you for a few days but you
go you know what [__] it
i'm gonna [__] be a man up go in
there
apologize do what i gotta do
and that's it and that's what this whole
thing was about
i want him to get that anger out of his
heart i'm gonna light a candle for you
i'm gonna pray for you
i want this anger out of your heart
because you don't need it
you're a young man the comedy store and
everything
that had to do it was a long long time
ago and i know a lot of people
that have a beef with that documentary
and i'm not mad at the producers or
listen there was just too many people to
cover
you know there was too many people to
cover and you know maybe they forgot
where you were
but uh as far as john
you didn't get to be on that and you
were a major part of that store
but next time learn to be a little bit
more humble and if you're watching this
and you're a young comic no matter how
big and bad and famous you get
learn to be humble learn to compliment
but also learn to say you're sorry you
know what i'm saying
i learned to it worked for me thank you
very much
for watching another fun-filled
uncle joey's joint on a monday let me
see if we covered everything here
because i don't ever want you to [__]
uh
say that [__] joey didn't give us
everything he had to i want to show you
something these are the patreon shirts
that came in
long sleeve just in case you're a junkie
you know me i do all my shirts long
sleeve
because i don't want no problems
sometimes people are junkies
and they're like joey what the [__]
so i don't know what i'm doing next but
i will be putting these online for sale
there's some hoodies left uh
there's some church of what's happening
now hoodies left
and uh that's it and that's that man
it's been a beautiful [__] week
it's a beautiful monday it's a beautiful
day to be alive
i'm excited to what's gonna uh what's
gonna happen new year's
it's thursday night maybe on thursday on
wednesday's podcast
we'll have a special announcement for
you on something to do on thursday night
and beside that that's it and that's
that i love you [__]
with all my heart i got no club dates
except the fifth and the sixth and uncle
vinnies
and uh the eighth i'm having my surgery
so there's not much
and we will try to do our podcast with
the [__] cast on
you know i'm not going to leave you in a
lurch because i have a little [__]
surgery going on
thank you very much thank you for
enjoying uncle joey's joint and now
for a word for my [__] sponsor
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening on a beautiful monday
it's a whole new week christmas is done
i'm sorry you know
you guys gotta take down your trees now
and cry and whatever but
you got a whole new [__] set a whole
new week and starts tonight
with the bills versus the [__]
patriots
because you know me the joint is brought
to you by
draftkings from the heart of
[__] south jersey
slinging dick off route 9 uncle joey's
here
and while the holiday season may be
winding down
the sports calendar is in full effect
this week
what do you got you got tonight you got
monday night football
then you got college basketball you got
nba basketball
then you're back to college [__]
football then you're back to nba
nfl [__] football next weekend this
is the week to make geezers right here
you can make your whole [__] year
right here if you do it smart
correctly and methodically you
understand me and that's why uncle joey
comes in
there's no better place to get in on
action than draftkings
why joey because they're america's
top-rated
sports book and if you haven't tried
them yet what the [__] are you waiting
for
flowers to celebrate this year's college
football playoffs
after you pick up 25 [__] 100 tonight
okay a nickel player tonight picked up
2500.
draftkings is giving all new users the
chance
to bet on any semi final team
to win the championship at 100 to one
odds
so you're gonna go into the week with
2500 are you kidding me
you know the damage you're gonna do you
dumb [__] you heard me right
all you gotta do is bet a buck
on enemy any semi-final team to win the
championship
and if your team wins ooh that's a
hundred hours who's getting that dick
sucked on new year's eve
by a chinese chick with one eye you
that's who
and don't forget the basketball head to
the app now
to check out the daily odds boost
they're [__] tremendous
and only draftkings could do them like
this if you're having some
if you haven't signed up yet today is
the day enough with the [__] [__]
you got some [__] cards from came on
walmart
your grandmother worked hard i know
somebody gave you a saving bond
[__] that who gives a [__] if it's going
to be worth 1000 10 years
you don't need that money then you need
it now [__]
go to the post office cash it in and
let's get draftkings on the phone
[__] mr bills against the patriots
tonight what are you [__] getting me
or what
the bills are mine is [__] seven this
is the way to [__] do it
and it starts tonight download the
top-rated draftking sportsbook app now
use promo code joey when you sign up to
get 100 to one odds
on any semi-final team listen to me
team to win it all that code that coach
joey's for new players
to get a shot at 100 to one odds but i
told you you start tonight
you got the winner of the bill's [__]
uh patriots game so you're gonna go into
the week with 2500
you're gonna bet these bold games a
dollar a piece
the amount of money you're gonna make is
gonna be insane
you're gonna have three women over your
house [__] lighting [__] melting
[__] strawberry candle wax in your
[__]
have you ever had that feeling no that's
what pimps and players do that's what
you are
it's the [__] last week of the year
you want to go out with [__] listen
you either you either want to kill
yourself you want to miss an
eye you want chlamydia you want
something you want a story
to start january 1. it's been a long
[__] year
draftkings is the answer we're getting
the party started so download
the top-rated draftking sports pickup
clay
use promo code joy when you sign up you
pick up 100 to one odds on any
semi-final theme
to win it all that's code joey for new
players to get a shot at 100
on any semi-final this [__] week
and that's for a limited time only at
draftkings sports book
tell them uncle joey sent you and this
is the part the lawyers make me say look
you got to be 21 or old all right
if not go play in traffic what are you
bothering me for go build the fort with
your [__] [__] friends
this is new jersey indiana pennsylvania
tennessee colorado if sporting is legal
draftkings is there with a [__]
tuxedo on and a big dick
deposit bonus requires 25 times play
through
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now listen
it's like drug problem alcoholism people
have gambling problems
if that's one of you listen stay away
from here we don't want to encourage you
we don't want to enable you
call 1-800 gambler and if you're in
indiana called 1-800-9
wooded but if you don't give a [__]
about your kids [__] braces
or the flat tire or whatever let's do
let's get this party started today
now download the draftking sports app
use promo code joey
and let's make some money who gives a
[__] your daughter have one [__] up
tooth
it worked for dracula to work for her
you know what i'm saying
draftkings right now use code joey
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion
the best the best you understand me
what cbd go to cbdlion.com read all
about it
read about the third party lab results
read about what it can do for you the
benefits whether you have anxiety
whether you
have insomnia whether you have arthritis
pain
listen this is not a cure-all but cbd
line is one of the best things to help
you
to manage from day to day whether it's
the tincture
the chocolate the dark chocolate the
milk chocolate
the vapor pens the bath balls the
tremendous gummies which i live off
that's why you know i love the tropical
they're [__] tremendous
and the uh roller ball
they got the cream they got everything
go to cbdlion.com right now read up on
cbn
read up on turbines read up on
third-party lab results
especially read what it could do for you
and then get back to me
they're tremendous if you see something
you like go to the box
pressing joey at church and get 20 off
delivered to your house they can't make
it any simpler for you
that's a real product line i believe in
them i live and die from
cbdline.com preston joey or
church also draftkings
press and joey to get the party started
you know what i'm saying
you might as well take some cbd get your
dick strong
get some [__] money and you're ready
for [__] thursday night for new
year's eve
when some chick is running down your
block with an eye patch on you know what
i'm saying who gives a [__]
here you go the mind of joey diaz is
always with you on patreon
three five and ten dollars i don't know
we're gonna do with the 15
tier yet but whatever the mind the vote
joey diaz is always there for you i love
you [__]
have a great week stay black and
uh i'll see you [__] wednesday that's
it and that's that
so
you